sono già in trip bel a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
faringei e facciano intro molto
tranquilla perché oggi è questo che
state per vedere un gioco che da una
vita e mezza non facevo è stato uno dei
miei primi video sul canale che si
chiama anti chamber è un gioco fatto di
qua quando beve tè è giocata questa roba
va beh l'ho pagato 20 euro quello già
solo per questo mi manda in botta ai un
pavimento finto wow bene le ragazze la
vi spiego e questo gioco dove c'è questo
porca vacca
ok sono vivo e molto come se fossi sotto
effetto di lsd in realtà prove quota faq
è la madonna non capisco una sega
rispecchia le lezioni di italiano che
faceva un tempo
ok questa porta si chiude quando mi
avvicino mi fa piacere a quando non
guardi e attenzione
[Musica]
all è perfetto è un prete pieno di
enigmi se così vogliamo chiamarli ma
tutti strani tutti tipo tipo lsd non
migliora non sto capendo
niente questo ho speso 20 euro
mi interessa saperlo cinque anni
dall'ultima tac omesso mano a questo
gioco effettivamente fosse capivo più
prima che adesso sinistra sicuro perché
a me piace qua a destra
io vado a destra su che cosa cosa dovrei
vedere o che bello inferno paradiso
assolutamente ma stai scherzando
c'era neanche da discutere vai dobbiamo
continuare così per tanto
ok va bene prendiamoci un po di tempo
perché effettivamente nel momenti così
per un po però andiamo in paradiso
vediamo che succede a proprio
continuiamo così a vita
va bene che abbiamo una canzone nel
mentre mi challengers diving normali
bello no no no
che palle abbiamo una fine in questa
roba così
[Musica]
non è che a pietro schifoso l'aido devo
tornare indietro se potevo continuare
così per tutta la vita quindi se io
stavo andando avanti con livio
probabilmente cielo cascato anche cinque
anni fa in sta roba non me lo ricordavo
ok esk premendo esche posso tornare ogni
volta qua figata e va bene allora
andiamo dove volevano dovevo andare
abbiamo qua cioè ragazzi è veramente un
casino sto gioco perché intricatissimo
certamente non ho mai visto che cos'è a
cena la pistola ancora la potevo
prendere non so come ma la potevo
prendere me lo ricordo a questo è tanto
di inizio
bene oggi su ok
devo fare dove andare lì con ci vado lì
scusa
mamma ho mai avuto una madre 9 questa
europea in generale ma com'è come non è
possibile ma non vedo la transizione che
incredibile casse mago otelma
se il check nobile ma mi fai aumentare
gli iscritti in modo sproporzionato non
si sa con magia e qualcosa per entrare
io devo solo devo credere di essere lì
dentro ok io sono qui dentro non
funziona più
sa io sono qui dentro bene ha funzionato
tara da letto bene non mi ricordo a cosa
serve sta roba però apre serbatoi e
liquidi cubi
ok a posizionare incubi per tenere ferme
le cose ok fantastico
mamma mia che figata fino ad ora ragazzi
ma la sto cavando super bene sono
veramente forte ben 20 euro ben spesi se
è così non troppo ben spesi 2
ok mamma mia ragazzi giocatore
incredibile
guardali all e non so quanto tempo avevo
risolto sta roba cinque anni fa però
ecco siamo io e la mia ragazza
devi andare giusto passo
la capisce ora non sto capendo una mazza
ma ne va avanti già salve
questa è la pen tunnel per la free enzo
no non è vero non finisce mai la finanza
nell fake cosa mi rappresenta
troppa curiosità può portare al meglio
di noi stessi
ma se lo dici tu guarda ancora ma basta
don't look da un ritorno il giorno
guardo giù è dopotutto stavolta
ma cosa devo fare esattamente a parte
cadere giù torno indietro
si potrà tornare indietro fantastico
quanta roba a posso prenderli tutti a
non sapevo che vai vai
devo riuscire no porca vacca poi non ce
l'ho ancora andato in teoria quindi non
mi ricordo cosa cosa diavolo è sta roba
vabbè non me lo ricordavo così sincero
madonna ma che figata
c'è è un gioco dai the trip incredibile
suo gioco non me lo ricordavo così
questo io che pago gli occhi e facci
iscritti
io che finisco di cagare a puoi passarci
in mezzo a fantastico io sto finito
figata
bene st romano la ricordavo devo seguire
un percorso in particolare o no
già misto entry parma donna ragazzi
mandavo vitara giocherà sta roba madonna
quanto brutto ok perfetto paga non so
neanche dove sto andando non è vita mi
bruciano gli occhi voglio morire o pasta
aglio tornare indietro
cade così mi piglia per il culo sempre
la facciano dovevo torna indietro sai
fare alcune scelte possono farci correre
in cerchio
arriviamo ai dieci minuti di video che
monetizza di più sono tornati qua porca
vacca commerce cioè sono stata l'inizio
fermi tutti ho bisogno di capire una
roba due episodi avevo fatto due episodi
due episodi avevo fatto sto male ma è la
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti gli
squalificati videocamera di merda cioè
in due episodi ero riuscito ad arrivare
dove è arrivato adesso c'è in due
episodi da un quarto d'ora l'uno
spessore grazie pubblicità con e topo ad
agno baker anna che reichert bravi a
tutti i ragazzi e bella sticazzi a uno
da 20 minuti e basta
va bene così like son state varate 2016
a c'è gente che guardassero ponendo
quindi 17 anche problemi avete favi che
bei tempi facilità di 20 minuti ora
invece i video non durano niente solo 8
minuti fa vi perché non li prendi a fare
video di 20 perché adesso in 8 minuti
faccio quello che una volta facciamo in
20 cosa c'è alla fine non farmi squadra
e voglio dire basta alla fine
[Musica]
ma che cosa straca
aleksander prus dopo tutto sto casino
la ricompensa che ricevi se vinci adanti
chamber e alexander bruce ai ragazzi io
concludo con l'episodio di anti chamber
è stato molto più in pappa cervello di
quanto mi ricordassi però che vi sia
piaciuto io ho fatto quello che potevo
per la mia mente ristretta è già tanto
se vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa il
momento mi piace è stato un bel tuffo
nel passato per ricordarmi come iniziato
tutto poi da quando ho fatto il video
santi cembre ho iniziato a fare sul
serio sul mio canale perché il mio
cervello era andato in pappa adesso mi
si è riassestato il cervello dopo averci
giocato quindi finiscono i video da
ragazzi
[Musica]